fox news alert a big win for houses of
worship the supreme court
siding with religious groups who sued
new york governor andrew cuomo
for his coronavirus restrictions good
morning everyone
happy thanksgiving i'm julie banderas
happy thanksgiving to you and yours as
well i'm leland vinner this case could
have big implications
not only for religious institutions but
also for businesses
as well governor cuomo had tried to
limit the number of people who could
tend
religious services but the supreme court
in a 5-4 ruling said that order violated
constitutional protections for
freedom of religion with the new
associate justice amy coney barrett in
the majority
chief justice john roberts in his
dissenting opinion
said it was not the court's place to
override determinations
by public health officials concerning
what is necessary for public safety
in the midst of a deadly pandemic
david spunt has more from washington so
david is this the beginning of the new
era
of the court with justice barrett now at
the bench good morning it really could
be julie happy thanksgiving to you
leland happy thanksgiving to you
just as amy coney barrett could be
sitting on the high court for another 40
plus years and often it's those first
few decisions that people really look at
especially this issue of religious
freedom
you mentioned a 5-4 ruling justice
barrett siding with the conservatives
on this matter and while justice chief
justice john roberts i should say chief
justice john roberts
is a devout catholic he sided with the
liberal
wing on this decision to allow these
gatherings
to go forward now the ruling came down
just before
midnight the decision is in favor of
those who want to exercise religious
freedom by gathering together during the
middle of this deadly pandemic
new york governor andrew cuomo announced
various restrictions on gathering
several months ago
as a way to halt the pandemic or at
least stop further spread
two religious groups a jewish group in a
christian group sued the majority
contended that cuomo's rulings violated
the freedom of religion clause
of the first amendment to the
constitution governor cuomo another
devout catholic
has kept the same message for months he
insists in the name of health
and safety i don't mean
little violations
you're only supposed to have 50 they had
55.
i'm talking about you're only supposed
to have 50 outdoors
they had
1 000 the ruling is also significant in
that it's a 180
from earlier supreme court rulings over
the spring and summer
allowed governors in nevada and
california to restrict attendance
at different religious institutions but
the difference there
during those decisions justice ruth
bader ginsburg was still living she
passed
away in september but she was still on
the court at that time
meaning that she ruled in the majority
five to four to allow
those local governors to make those
restrictions but now justice barrett on
the court
clearly clearly julie a win for
religious freedom today
back to you all right david spun thank
you
leland thank you